it was Wednesday evening around nine  p.m. local time when a white man in his  early twenties entered the church  members of the congregation were in the  midst of bible study witnesses say he  was there for an hour before opening  fire police have no doubt about the  shooters motivation I do believe this  was a hate crime is that way the FBI is  years again investigated of a Negro the  Emanuel Church is home to one of the  oldest and largest black congregations  in the south it's a fixture in  Charleston a city known for its  religious diversity people are shocked  that such an attack could happen here  have a awful person come in  shootin is is inexplicable obviously the  most intolerable and unbelievable act  possible police are searching for the  gunman with helicopters and sniffer dogs  and among residents anger and sadness in  equal measures as the city joins others  affected by heightened racial tensions  in the u.s.